este vídeo compartido por ammar news en
afganistán muestra la zona atacada con
aviones no tripulados estadounidenses
allí murió el jefe de al qaeda ayman
al-zawahiri 11 años después que osama
bin-laden una gran victoria para estados
unidos después del caótico retiro del
gobierno de afganistán el año pasado y
el regreso al poder de los talibanes
ahora se ha hecho justicia y este
terrorista ya no existe dejamos en claro
nuevamente esta noche que no importa
cuánto tiempo tome no importa donde se
escondan si son una amenaza para nuestra
gente eeuu los encontrará y los sacará
con state of you
el terrorista nacido en egipto y autor
intelectual de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre estaba en el balcón de su
casa cuando fue ejecutado baiden dijo
quien ningún civil murió en el operativo
los talibanes confirmaron previamente
que la casa atacada se encontraba en una
zona de lujo en el centro de kabul
periodistas y medios de comunicación han
identificado la casa y el equipo de
observadores france24 la ha rastreado
hasta este lugar cercano a la embajada
británica funcionarios de inteligencia
aseguraron que obtuvieron información
que zawahiri y su familia se mudaron
este año y lo siguieron durante meses
los talibanes condenaron el ataque y
aseguraron que se violó el acuerdo de
paz de doha de 2020 en el que eeuu
aceptó retirarse por completo de
afganistán en el mismo acuerdo los
talibanes se comprometieron a no ayudar
ni a acoger a grupos terroristas el
departamento de estado de eeuu dice que
los gobernantes afganos estaban al tanto
del cambio de vivienda de zawahiri